[Music]
I've spent plenty of time on the show
explaining my problem with studies and
there's nothing wrong in principle with
the idea of conducting a study doing a
study just means that you're studying
something I'm not opposed to that the
problem as I've argued is that so many
studies use shoty methodology in order
to arrive at a predetermined conclusion
and then those same studies are used as
ammunition and political arguments by
people who haven't read them but on the
other end of the spectrum are studies
that are entirely valid and reach
legitimate conclusions by following the
scientific process
and yet are still a waste of time
because they prove something that
everyone should already know intuitively
without any scientific study telling
them you have studies that come to fake
conclusions and then you have studies
that come to foregone conclusions
self-evident conclusions this week the
media is reporting on one that falls
very much into that latter category or
at least I would have hoped that it
falls into the latter category I would
like to believe that everyone already
knows this and doesn't need any
scientific research to tell them but uh
maybe perhaps it turns out I'm wrong CNN
reports quote handing your baby maybe a
phone or tablet to play with may seem
like a harmless solution when you're
busy but it could quickly affect their
development a new study has found now
it's a brief sidebar here I guess my
initial theory has already taken a hit
the optimistic part of me a part that is
growing smaller and smaller by the day
would have liked to think that every
parent understands that g you know
giving your getting your baby your baby
hooked on a tablet is most certainly not
a harmless solution nor is it a healthy
way to deal with the busyness of life
but that's not the impression you get
from the first sentence of this article
and reading on quote having anywhere
from 1 to 4 hours of screen time per day
at age 1 is linked with higher risks of
Developmental delays in communication
fine motor uh problem solving and
personal and social skills by age two
according to a study of 7,097 children
published Monday in the journal jamama
Pediatrics quote it's a really important
study because it has a very large sample
size of children who've been followed by
for several years said Dr Jason Nagata
associate professor Pediatric to the
University of California San Francisco
who was not involved in the study quote
the study fills an important Gap because
it identifies specific developmental
delays in skills such as communication
and problem solving associated with
screen time said nagato noting there
haven't been many prior studies that
studied this issue with several years of
follow-up data now I just want to
emphasize this four hours of screen time
at age one four hours at age one keep in
mind that children at age one I mean
these are babies we're talking about
people are plopping their baby
in front of screens for 4 hours
apparently but children at that age they
typically nap twice a day so you you
know you might get three or four hours
of napping out of a baby most likely
also you're putting them down for bed
like at 8 or 8:30 maybe earlier the
point is that they're only awake for
seven or hour seven or eight hours a day
which means that four hours of screen
time is half of their waking hours at
the age of
one this is what parents are doing
apparently and here are the results of
that parenting decision quote the study
measured how many hours children used uh
screens per day at age one and how they
performed in several developmental
domains communication skills F motor
skills personal and social skills and
problem solving skills at ages two and
four both measures were according to the
Mother self-reports by age two those who
had up to four hours of screen time per
day were up to three times more likely
to experience develop developmental
delays in communication and problem
solving skills those who had spent four
or more hours with screens were 4.8
times more likely to have underdeveloped
communication skills 1.7 times more
likely to have subpar fine motor skills
and two times more likely to have
underdeveloped personal and social
skills by age two potential harms of
screen time on communication skills may
have have to do with children being
robbed of drivers for language
development technology use can take time
away from interpersonal relationships
that nurture social skills since real
people are more multi-dimensional than
characters on a screen looking at
people's faces is when our uh brains uh
when our brains turn on to figure out
how to interact with them if children
don't have enough time to play or or
handed a tablet to pacify negative
emotions that can prevent the important
developmental milestone that is the
ability to navigate
discomfort now normally I'm skeptical of
studies that depend on self-reported
data but that's because participants are
inevitably biased in their own favor
when self-reporting what that means for
This research is that actually the
situation is probably much worse than
what we're told if parents are going to
skew the data at all they they'll do it
to undercount the amount of time their
kids spend on screens and under estimate
the developmental delays seems very
unlikely that any parent would
exaggerate the amount of screen time to
make it sound like they plop their kids
in front of screens more often than they
really do so the point is that the real
story is even more concerning than
what's presented here that's especially
the case when you zoom out and view the
problem through a wider lens kids are
kids are put on screens as we you know
as we've now seen practically from birth
and they'll stay on them through their
entire childhood hardly taking a break
hardly ever looking up to take in the
physical world around around them it's
difficult to find Reliable estimates on
the average amount of time kids are
spending on screens in part because this
data is again always going to be
self-reported and the people doing the
self-reporting are incentivized to
underestimate but even with that
limitation the surveys I've seen all
seem to agree that children between the
ages of8 and 18 spend on average around
eight or nine hours a day on screens
I've seen some estimates at say 10 hours
and that's just for entertainment
purposes doesn't count school work it's
even harder to find Reliable estimates
for kids younger than eight but we know
that they they don't suddenly jump on
the screens at 8 years old and spend
eight hours on them um so we know that
and eight or nine hours of screen time
is probably an extremely conservative
estimate yet even taking it at face
value this would mean that millions of
children are essentially spending every
waking moment when they're not in school
staring at
screens this is their whole
life and most of that time is spent bent
on phones and tablets not on the TV a
survey back in 2019 found that over half
of kids in the US have phones with
internet access by the age of 11 20% of
children have them before the age of
eight that's phones with internet access
before the age of eight it was in 2019
so we could be sure that those numbers
have all gone up considerably in the
four years since the survey was
conducted and although plenty of studies
including the most recent one have
revealed some of the damage this is
doing to our kids no study can paint a
complete picture
we're only just now beginning to see
what that looks like what the full
picture is as the first generation of
kids raised from birth on screens
smartphones internet begins to reach
adulthood and the results are quite dire
only getting worse over time I mean gen
Z is the fattest lonliest most depressed
most anxious least motivated least
ambitious generation of human beings to
ever live on the planet all the
statistics bear that
out they they have difficulty forming
human connections and relationships uh
they're mostly uninterested in even
trying they're deeply confused about
themselves about the world incredibly
ignorant gender confusion has reached
never before seen highs in this group
they spent their whole lives staring at
screens they never knew life without it
and that's having exactly the kind of
impact that any rational person should
expect so why would parents set their
children up for this why would you do
this to your kid
why would you intentionally put your
child in a position where they will
become totally addicted to and dependent
on screens and unable to function as
normal human beings in the world without
them why would you actively ensure that
your your child has unfettered access to
the
internet where he'll be exposed to all
manner of ugliness and depravity and
degeneracy which he'll absorb and
internalize during the formative years
of his
life why would you allow your child to
spend 8 nine 10 hours a day laying
around and staring at a little glowing
box instead of going out into the fresh
air and having a real childhood whether
he likes it or not as many of you know
I'm a true Grill Master I love grilling
up just about anything thanks to my
friends at cinch my grill is never empty
with propane because of this I can uh
have whatever I want whenever I want on
the grill cinch is a propane grill tank
Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule does not
require any long-term commitment or
subscription Plus delivery is completely
contactless so you don't have to wait
around at home you can track the order
on the Cinch app from wherever you
happen to be whether you're grilling for
the sweet baby gang camping with your
family or lighting up your fire pit on a
cold summer night CES propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go online to cinch.com or
download their app to order new
customers can uh get their first tank
exchange for just $10 with promo code
Walsh that's Cyn ch.com promo code Walsh
it's a limited time offer and you must
live within a cinch service area to
redeem it visit cinch.com / offer for
details well whatever answer parents
might give whatever they tell themselves
the truth is clear me they do it out of
sheer laziness and some will actually
admit this here's one mother on Tik Tok
explaining in the very Tik Tock way why
she gives her kids tablets
watch because they're annoying she says
the video she why why would you give
your your kids tablets she says because
they're annoying like the kids are
annoying that's what she's saying uh
she's a bad mother in other words she
she she want to make a video to let
everyone know that she's a bad mother it
very important to let everyone know now
that video has 5,000 likes many mothers
have jumped into the comment section to
give their amens uh one says quot LOL I
like your thinking totally guilty of
this too another says they really do be
like that though it's the only thing
besides sticking their hands in Outlets
that keeps them occupied LMAO another
says as my kid sits there on her phone
and I'm on my phone ah silence another
says yes I just bought the twins one
many similar comments and then there's
this only full-time parents would
understand is that so well I'm a
full-time parent I have six kids all
them 10 and younger three under four
years old uh none of them have phones or
tablets and I can guarantee you my wife
and I have much busier lives than any of
the women in that comment section by a
considerable margin probably now look
we're not perfect parents by any stretch
of imagination but the point is that
parents who pull this well you'll
understand when you're a parent yeah you
might judge parents for giving their
kids tablets and having them on the
screens but when you're a parent you'll
understand no that's a cope that's a
rationalization you are lazy and
neglectful you're more worried about
making your kid shut up and leave you
alone than actually raising him and
helping him to become a good happy
well-adjusted
person uh you're a parent who doesn't
want to parent
and mostly you don't want a parent so
that you can spend all of your time on
your own
screen okay your entire home life is
centered around the screen it has it has
the screen has cannibalized everything
it has defined you and your family
you're not even a family you're just a
you're just a a collection of human
beings living in the same house staring
at
screens is this really the kind of life
you want is it the kind of life you want
your kid to
have what is the point of a life that is
spent doing nothing but staring
mindlessly at a glowing
box these are the questions you should
ask
yourself and if you're giving a tablet
to your one-year-old to spend hours a
day
on then you really need to ask yourself
this
question in the meantime put down the
screen take the screen away from your
child take him outside play a board game
with with him play hideand-seek have a
conversation if you can imagine read him
a book like do something for God's sake
love your child enough to pay attention
to him for more than 30 seconds at a
time takes a little bit of effort but
it's not so difficult as you think it's
worth a try at
least otherwise you're canceled hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two month free on all annual
plans see you there